the long now foundation owns property
that's home to a number of ancient
bristlecone pine trees
researchers have been able to sample
these and use tree ring analysis to see
how the growth rate varied from year to
year as a result of changes in weather
sometimes the effects are obvious enough
that anyone can just see them by looking
at a slice of the wood but there are
also special staining techniques that
can make the changes more obvious
2036 bce was apparently marked by a
large volcanic eruption that left a
clear discontinuity in the sample on the
left the sample on the right shows a
couple of anomalous years around 1419
bce
you can identify them from the blue
fringes in the staining
here's a plot of tree ring data what's
being plotted here is the thickness of
the rings which gives you an idea of
growing conditions
year by year a higher value suggests a
better growing season a low value
suggests that the weather was bad i've
superimposed some vertical red lines
showing the dates of some of the big
eruptions mentioned in neil fergus's
book some of the big drops are
observable in years following some of
the big eruptions notably
lombok indonesia which is the left most
one
and the one in peru but in other cases
like lockheed
there's not much of a change so this is
kind of interesting
in that you don't always see a strong
one-to-one correlation between these
eruptions these volcanic events and
whether in a particular part of the
world there's a global effect
but those effects are distributed
just because of the complexity of
atmospheric physics
here's a similar chart in the lower part
of the chart you're seeing two plots a
bunch of spikes drawn in black
which are telling you the amount of
volcanic aerosols in the atmosphere so
for example there's a super high spike
in the late 1200s this
group here is probably tambora around
1816.
this one here is probably locky and so
on and so forth
so
then the blue line is showing how much
the temperature is thought to have
deviated from average and again the
correlations aren't always perfectly one
for one we see a big drop
after tambora
down here but there's other cases where
nothing seems to happen
at the other end of the 19th century
edvard munch painted this famous
masterpiece the dramatic red sky in the
background is open to interpretation of
course but the painting was made not
long after the eruption of krakatoa
which depressed temperatures all over
the world
and created spectacular sunsets like
this one for a couple of years
afterwards
in the 1960s yet another eruption in
indonesia put a plume of ejecta into the
atmosphere the australians got a plane
in the air to take samples when it
landed they noticed a deposit
on the windscreen
one of the australian scientists licked
it
and reported that it was painfully acid
a more sophisticated analysis found
that it was sulfates
sulfuric acid basically
in 1991 when mount pinatubo erupted in
the philippines it was possible to
gather a lot more scientific data beyond
the now familiar
empirical
sensations of depressed global
temperatures and brilliant sunsets this
is all quite well understood when sulfur
dioxide is injected into the
stratosphere it combines with available
water to form sulfuric acid which drifts
around in the form of a very large
number of tiny
droplets when such a droplet is struck
by light from the sun some of the light
will bounce back into space
so it never reaches the troposphere
which is where weather happens and it
can't warm up the planet
some of the light will be deflected
sideways this contributes to a general
brightening of the sky
that explains the beautiful sunsets as
well as some of the mysterious
atmospheric phenomena described by those
byzantine and scandinavian sources as
well as benjamin franklin himself
and some of the light keeps going down
and continues to warm the earth as usual
this keeps happening for a couple of
years which is how long it takes for the
sulfates to wash out of the atmosphere
then everything goes back to normal
sulfates have remarkable leverage
against global temperatures the amount
of sulfates needed to cool down the
earth by one or two degrees simply isn't
that large
it's easy to imagine engineered delivery
systems that would duplicate what
volcanoes have done many times in the
past
high altitude tanker planes high
altitude balloons and big guns have all
been mentioned
this kind of thing goes under the name
solar geoengineering
it's a perfectly well known concept
among scientists who study these things
but it doesn't get talked about much
because it's controversial
unfortunately the co2 level in the
atmosphere keeps on rising regardless
this is a screen grab from just a few
days ago showing that the current level
is about 414
parts per million
that's up from 411 in the last year
the graph on the lower right
just happens to begin around the time i
was born
and
it shows that just during my lifetime
it's gone from below 320 parts per
million to almost 420.
and if you look at the shape of that
curve not only is it going up which
means that the problem is getting worse
but it's got a little upward curve to it
indicating that the pace at which it's
getting worse is accelerating
prior to the industrial revolution this
number was in the mid 200s today it's
the highest it has been since a few
million years ago
when the world had a completely
different climate
various governments have announced plans
to cut back on carbon dioxide emissions
china for example is saying that by 2030
their emissions will level off in other
words if they do that and every other
country in the world does likewise the
co2 level will at that point become a
mere linear function of time it'll still
be going up at an impressive rate but
the rate itself won't be increasing this
plot will no longer have that slight
upward curve
it'll just be a straight ramp angling
upwards by something like 2060 or 2070
it's hoped that the world economy might
reach net zero carbon emissions
this doesn't solve the problem it'll
turn this curve into a flat horizontal
line if the co2 level in the atmosphere
is say 500 parts per million in 2070
it'll remain at 500 until natural
processes can bring it back down again
which is expected to take on the order
of a million years
there are a lot of ways in which this is
bad but perhaps the most serious threat
that we can expect to see materialize in
coming years is that of so-called wet
bulb disasters in which temperature and
humidity both get so high is to make the
survival of humans a physical
impossibility
kim stanley robinson's ministry for the
future opens with a harrowing depiction
of one such event in india
that all sounds pretty bad and like the
kind of thing that a well-ordered
society would mount an effective
response to but we're at the end of
almost two years of a global pandemic in
which a significant fraction of people
refuse to believe in the very existence
of a disease that's killing people
all around them in the hundreds of
thousands
so from all of this it's completely
obvious that the human race is going to
have to build carbon capture
technologies on an incredibly massive
scale
if you think of this in terms of all the
coal mines that have been hollowed out
of the earth's crust all of the
petroleum deposits that have been
drained
all of the forests and peat bogs that
have been burned basically we have to
fill those back up again with stable
carbon containing compounds that we'll
have to manufacture
we'll need to do it fast
it'll be by far the largest engineering
project in the history of the world i
believe that we will do it and that a
hundred years from now this problem will
have been solved atmospheric co2 levels
will be back to where they were before
the industrial revolution
that's the good news
the bad news is that it's going to take
decades and during that time we're going
to begin seeing disastrous events such
as the one depicted in the ministry for
the future
on those rare occasions when people talk
about solar geoengineering at all it's
conventional to describe it as an idea
that's on the extreme fringe and that
deserves to be there because it seems so
dangerous
much more research is needed is the
usual conclusion
i do wonder whether it will continue to
seem all that dangerous a decade or two
down the road
when climate disasters are leading
directly to mass fatalities
particularly given the fact that nature
has already performed the experiment for
us on several occasions
and we know that the sulfates naturally
wash out of the atmosphere in a couple
of years
danger is always relative jumping out of
a moving car is dangerous but people
will do it anyway if the car is about to
go over a cliff
so in my book termination shock an
individual billionaire constructs a
large gun that shoots sulfur into the
stratosphere simulating what volcanoes
do
this is already a fedocom plea at the
beginning of the story and so what it's
mostly about is how people react to it
needless to say not everyone is happy
just to give some sense of scale the
amount of sulfur that this fictional gun
is capable of launching over the course
of a year's continuous operation is only
about one percent of what mount pinatubo
put into the air explosively
but in his mind it's just a pilot
project and the plan is to build more
such facilities in other parts of the
world
and that is the setup for a kind of
geopolitical
uh thriller that is is essentially the
story of those who uh those who are
happy about this plan and those who are
extremely unhappy
you